in case you somehow miss it it looks
like there is some pretty big news
coming from Xbox next week this started
with rumors that XBox exclusive sea of
Thieves and high-fi Rush would be coming
to PlayStation 5 then more rumors from
The Verge that Indiana Jones and
Starfield might also be coming to PS5
and all of this has caused chaos amongst
console Fanboys but we finally have a
little bit of word from Phil Spencer
Xbox head Phil Spencer tweeted saying
we're listening and we hear you we've
been planning a business update event
for next week where we look forward to
sharing more details with you about our
vision for the future of Xbox stay tuned
this also comes just after Amy hoodu was
Chief Financial Officer at Microsoft
said that there was a weaker than
expected performance for the console
Market being Xbox and she said it on an
earnings call you can't really tell
investors on an earnings call that
something is going wrong unless you're
also right about to tell them how you
intend to fix it still all speculative
at this point but I'm very interested to
see what they have to say next week and
how do you guys feel about this